all people no matter who they are
who wish they'd appreciated life more
is what you do in life that's important
not how much time you have Mrs Wang are
you with us
absolutely blow my mind
that's impossible
that wouldn't be a sin though would it
fine
are you ready
to make
my God
[Music]
[Applause]
hello good afternoon everyone a very
warm welcome to EE bafta film Awards
nominations announcement 2023 I'm Hayley
Atwell and I'm taheed Jamal hello
everyone it's a great honor to reveal
this year's nominees from bafta's home
here in London congratulations to
everyone involved in the films on this
year's long list it's clearly been a
year of outstanding films and inspiring
performances you're all winners of my
eyes agreed but it's not up to us voting
for the film Awards is undertaken by
bafta's film voting members that's over
7 000 film industry professionals here
in the UK and worldwide and looking at
that Montage the bafta voters are going
to have a hard time picking the winners
there is one award that is voted for by
the public and that's the ee Rising Star
Award I was lucky enough to be part of
the jury that selected this year's very
special and hugely talented ee Rising
Star nominees here's a reminder of who
you can vote for
Amy Lou wood
Daryl McCormack
Emma Mackey
Naomi Aki
and Sheila atom
get voting everyone the ee Rising Star
Award winner and all of this year's ee
back the film Award winners will be
revealed on the 19th of February at 7 pm
on BBC One and BBC iPlayer in the UK the
ceremony will be hosted by Richard E
Grant and Alison Hammond will host a
brand new bafta studio we're in for an
unmissable night we are indeed the heart
of bafta's mission as an Arts charity is
to recognize exceptional stories and
storytellers and the skill and expertise
of the many talented people that work to
realize them on screen
the awards are a vital part of this
year-round work
they provide opportunity and access for
current and future screen industry
creatives regardless of their background
or life experience
and bafta is the only organization doing
this across film games and television
to be nominated for a bafta is a truly
incredible achievement so without
further ado
let's reveal this year's nominations all
right first up
the nominees for outstanding British
film are
after sun
the Banshees of inner Sharon
Brian and Charles
Empire of light
good luck to you Leo Grande
living
Roald Dahl's Matilda the Musical
See How They Run
the swimmers
the Wonder
the nominees for original screenplay are
Martin McDonough the Banshees vinishiran
Daniel Kwan and Daniel scheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Tony Kushner and Steven Spielberg the
fablemans
Todd field
tar
Reuben osland triangle of sadness
the nominees for adapted screenplay are
Edward Berger Leslie Patterson Ian
stockall All Quiet on the Western Front
kazuo ishiguro living
comb baraid the quiet girl
Rebecca lenkovic
she said
Samuel D Hunter the whale
the nominees for documentary are
all that breathes
all the Beauty and the bloodshed
fire of love
Moon age daydream
navalny
the nominees for film not in the English
language are
All Quiet on the Western Front
Argentina 1985.
corsage
decision to leave
the quiet girl
the nominees for outstanding debut by a
British writer director or producer are
Charlotte Wells after sun
Georgia Oakley and Helen seifra blue
jean
Marie lydian electric malady
Katie brand good luck to you Leo Grande
Maya Kenworthy
Rebellion
the nominees for director are
Edward Berger All Quiet on the Western
Front
Martin McDonough
the Banshees of inner Sharon
Park Chan wook the decision to leave
Daniel Kwon and Daniel scheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Todd field
tar
Gina Prince bathwood
the woman King
the nominees for supporting actor are
Brendan Gleason the Banshees of
innishiran
Barry Keegan the Banshees of innishiran
everything everywhere all at once
Eddie Redmayne the good nurse
Albrecht shook All Quiet on the Western
Front
Michael Ward Empire of light
the nominees for supporting actress are
Angela Bassett black panther wakanda
forever
Hong Chao the whale
Kerry Condon the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Dolly de Leon
triangle of sadness
Jamie Lee Curtis everything everywhere
all at once
Carrie Mulligan
she said
the nominees for leading actor are
Austin Butler Elvis
Colin Farrell the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Brendan Fraser the whale
Daryl McCormack good luck to you Leo
Grande
Paul meskel after sun
Bill Nye living
the nominees for leading actress are
Kate Blanchette tar
Viola Davis the woman King
Danielle deadweiler till
Ana de armas blonde
Emma Thompson good luck to you Leo Grand
and Michelle yo everything everywhere
all at once
the nominees for best film are
All Quiet on the Western Front
the Banshees of inner Sharon
Elvis
everything everywhere all at once
tar
finally these are the five most
nominated films this year
All Quiet on the Western Front with 14
nominations
the Banshees of inner Sharon with 10
nominations
everything everywhere all at once also
with 10 nominations
Elvis with nine nominations
and tar with five nominations huge
congratulations to all this year's
nominees we can't wait to celebrate with
you on the 19th of February it's been an
honor everyone please go to bafta's
website and social channels to see this
year's full list of nominations don't
forget to tune in to the ceremony next
month on BBC One and iPlayer in the UK
there will also be live coverage from
the red carpet on bafta's YouTube
channel hosted by Ali Plum and Vic hope
who you can catch any minute now live on
bafta's Instagram taking a look at this
year's nominees follow hashtag ee baftas
to join the conversation huge
congratulations again to all the
nominees
bye goodbye
[Applause]